hi this is Austin with a question for
Jocko willing I just want helpers
anywhere I can listen year old punk band
rage of discipline you brought up on the
Joe Rogan show I've been looking for it
but can't find it information would be
helpful thanks a lot love your work do
you ever play with Kyle Turley did you
guys ever cross paths I don't know
no don't know who that is who's Kyle
Turley he's uh he's an offensive lineman
for the Rams and and he had a punk band
and he also served in the military yeah
so I was when I was a kid like I said I
was a real rebellious kid and we were
always in bands now the band's meant you
know we're gonna go into my shed and
make noise they both like we were out on
tour anything like that but we did we
did go in the studio one time and we uh
we we put down some tracks I think we
put down like twelve or fifteen tracks
and my my bro who was in the band with
me who's now a guy up in LA Elgin James
he's actually a writer he's a writer and
he's he's got his own cool store you
could have him on the podcast yeah I'd
love to reach out to him yeah he's um
anyways I went in the military and he
ended up joining gang and kind of
getting crazy for a while and ended up
in federal prison for a little bit and
in the meantime he had broken away from
that scene and went to got started
making movies and he made a movie he
made a little short movie he got invited
to the Sundance Film Festival or the
Sundance Film Lab and he learned how to
how to make movies he ended up doing a
great movie called little birds and now
he there's a new program you ever heard
of sons of anarchy yeah so there's a
spinoff from Sons of Anarchy
it's called Mayans MC it's about a
Mexican motorcycle gang and anyways he's
Natisha yeah oh wow so he's writing that
thing interesting but but yeah when we
were kids me and him we're getting our
rock-and-roll on hardcore music and we
have the original what are they called
reel-to-reel tapes and we were just
talking about this reel-to-reel tapes is
like back in the day the win in a
recording studio when they got all these
different tracks so you need a thicker
tape to record all the tracks and so you
have these big like reels like a movie
like a lot
a wall or something yes so he's got the
tracks and we're finding a place right
now that can take those tracks and and
and burn them down onto a release a
couple yeah we're gonna get it real
we got like I think we got three songs
that are salvageable that would be worth
throwing out there so so yeah we'll do
it man we'll put out there and that
could be a new weapon that we would
change the name of the band like every
like six weeks or whatever because you
know we techno we're going in the new
direction right because we took
ourselves super seriously and so the the
the kind of the iconic name of the band
was Bronson's children after Charles
Bronson and we had these cool shirts
that had a picture of Charles Bronson
they had Bronson's children like little
kids riding on it and and so yeah yeah
so so I actually I actually reprinted
those and I and I sell them so people
people are representing the Bronson
children it oh so when I'm bringing it
back out yeah rage of discipline was the
name of the band for a little while was
rage discipline we were called struggle
we were called mocking both we had all
kinds of names man you know we'd have
like internal issues about the direction
and artistic control you know it is when
you're 14 and just playing in a punk
rock band you really just loud in the
garage oh yeah it's definitely loud at
the garage there's no doubt about that's
a reminds me of um have you ever had
Henry Rollins on I haven't but the
interesting thing about interesting man
yeah yeah so when I was a kid I was way
into Black Flag which was you know where
he originally played who's the vocalist
got brought in the Black Flag but so I
went on tour with when he went when he
left Black Flag he put out some albums
of his own in the beginning they were
called it was called Rollins band the
first one was called Henry out of
Collins but then he the next one was
called life time this is a great album
and when that album came out me and all
my friends from Bronson's children we
wouldn't on tour and we would go to
every show he'd play we I put we
probably went to like ten shows but we'd
saw my peers yeah yeah yeah and see that
the cool thing is this is back in the
day where you know we go to CBGB's and
show up at you know 3 o'clock in the
afternoon help him offload all their
gear help them get their gear set up as
much as we could hang out and it
it was like nah it was nothing man it's
kind of like what the UFC used to be
like when you just hang out with all the
fighters we just be hanging out with
everyone everyone's cool and so did that
with Rollins probably like I said to
probably 1 to 10 probably 10 shows but I
saw him a bunch of not a bunch probably
saw him five other times or eight other
times besides that and you know when I
was a kid Rollins was this kind of like
bigger than life kind of yeah cuz he was
but he's about 10 years older than me
and you know he you know he has like
Search and Destroy tattooed on his back
and he's like you know all hardcore and
you know that definitely influenced me
when I was a kid you know cuz I was like
13 14 13 that was your next band oh yeah
for sure and and there's a there's an
album called Black Flag my war and if
you listen to my war side too
it's this really slow as at first it was
a first kind of like really slow and
heavy music that started to mix the
hardcore in the punk with Black Sabbath
into one and so when I was a kid that
album side two of that album stayed on
my record plan for like a year straight
just play that over and over again
but and then so then I joined the
military
cuz I knew that's what I always wanted
to do and when uh it was probably 1992
whenever the first Lollapalooza remember
his rasul-allah Collins was playing
Lollapalooza and I I went and I didn't
have tickets or anything but I figured
if I could just get like hook up with
him he'd let me in cuz cuz you've seen
him so many times like we've seen him in
like the you know we would hang out you
know not not like Bros right but you
know hey man he's he's 26 at the time
right I'm 16 you know that's that's it
so he's looking at me like hey man this
guy's one of my one of my one of my
young people or whatever yeah and so
then fast forward a few years whatever
it is and I went to Lollapalooza and I
you know I was pretty good when I was a
kid at sneaking around and figuring
stuff over ah yeah covert operations and
I finally I got to him and he he looked
at me like he recognized me
who knows you know what I mean I meet a
lot he's meeting a lot of people over
the years but like I said you know we
were
he might recognize me who knows but I
was like hey man
I you know I went on tour these lifetime
tour 80 whatever was 86 or something 89
8 or 88 when I wasn't bleep it's like 86
it is sound and he goes oh yeah man
what's up and I was like hey man
any chance you could get us in you know
get me my boy here and I had some other
kid that was in the SEAL Teams with me
that was a hardcore kid and he I just
remember and say you he goes man to be
easier to get you into Fort Knox right
now they got this place on lockdown and
and he was cool and that was that and
then I saw him a couple years later at a
Cypress Hill I think it was hell on the
Beastie Boys and Rollins and saw him and
so that was that and so to answer your
question to have I had him on the
podcast the answer's no I haven't had
him on the podcast I talked about him on
the early podcast somebody asked me
about him and you know I kind of talked
about the fact that you know when I was
a kid hey man this guy was like super
hardcore and you know that's that he had
an influence on me when I was younger
and then you know as I got older you
know and I started I was you know like
he had search-and-destroy tattooed on
his back and like I was doing
search-and-destroy missions right so
there was a you think you're living at
his tattoos a little bit and but it'd be
interesting I definitely would like to
sit down a talker I'd like to find out
if he really actually remembers us
yeah because he might because he's a
smart man Ariella sure for sure and you
know it's I the guy had a and that band
had a big influence on these influence
it feels a lot of people yeah yeah did
you did you like that kind of music
growing up no IRA I would go to a
Cypress Hill um I went on that tour
actually he [ __ ] hit this hot girl
with my car in the parking lot and I
still feel bad about it a little bit she
was hot but did you injure her you know
what does everybody have a different
definition I think of what a name did
you have to bring her to the hospital
look we didn't have to you bro we were
running late okay but I think somebody
might have those are all that stuff we
were talking earlier about being a good
person here in the world I guess this
was pre feel this was high yeah high
school this is high literally
what's up guys sitting here with this
marijuana plant I think also could be
just a regular plant it could be poison
ivy brought about to smoke myself in
some itchy itchy just watch another clip
since you're already here you know I'm
saying